bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne à partir de midi les voeux
de nicolas sarkozy aux forces
économiques
c'est donc à partir de midi en direct de
l'elysée mais tout de suite place à la
séance je vous propose de suivre un
débat sur le service minimum dans les
transports
ce débat a été organisé mercredi à la
demande du groupe ump du sénat
objectif faire le bilan de la loi qui a
été votée en 2007 alors que la grève du
mois dernier dans le rer a a été la
grève la plus suivie depuis 1995 avec 90
à 95% de grévistes
voilà donc pour les enjeux de ce débat
que je vous propose de suivre tout de
suite très bonne machine à tous sur
notre antenne
la parole est donc à tout d'abord à
l'orateur du groupe qui a demandé ce
débat madame catherine procaccia pour le
groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues en 2007 la
loi sur le service minimum dans les
transports étaient selon les sondages
attendu par 70 ou 80 % de nos
concitoyens qui voulaient pouvoir se
rendre à leur travail en revenir aller
chez le médecin ou récupérer à temps les
enfants à l'école
pas moins de quinze propositions de loi
déposées sur le bureau de l'une ou
l'autre des assemblées avaient été
consacrés à ce sujet au cours des 20
dernières années
le président de la république a voulu
concrétiser très vite un engagement fort
de sa campagne électorale et ce dès
l'été 2007
mais c'est une loi sur le dialogue
social dans les transports terrestres de
voyageurs que nous avons voté
considérant que c'était le seul moyen
d'apporter une réponse concrète et
pragmatique
à cette préoccupation majeure il n'a
jamais été question de remettre en cause
le droit de grève qui est un droit
constitutionnel mais de l'aménager afin
de pouvoir trouver un point d'équilibré
avec d'autres droits tout aussi légitime
mais souvent oubliée la continuité
d'accès aux services publics la liberté
d'aller et de venir la liberté du
commerce et de l'industrie
la liberté du travail avec un droit de
grève large nous continuité de service
public très partiellement garanti un
dialogue social limité la france faisait
figure d'exception au sein de l'union
européenne où la moitié des états
membres a déjà instauré un service
minimum pour les services essentiels
c'est le cas de l'italie du portugal de
l'espagne de la grèce
pour l'autre moitié soit il n'y a pas de
culture des conflits importants comme en
suède en finlande ou en allemagne ou
parce que les draps du droit de grève
est strictement encadrée comme en grande
bretagne au royaume uni excusez moi s'en
remettre sans mettre en place une
véritable obligation de service minimum
qui aurait pu être censurée par le
conseil constitutionnel la loi du 21
août 2007 à instituer des règles pour
favoriser le dialogue social
ils permettent une meilleure
organisation des services de transport
public en garantissant aux usagers un
avis certes réduit mais prévisible en
cas de grève ou de fortes perturbations
la loi a aussi eu le mérite d'être mise
en oeuvre très rapidement puisque
débattu pendant l'été 2007 elle s'est
appliquée six mois après plus de trente
mois après l'adoption de la loi et deux
ans de sa mise en oeuvre
je pense que maintenant nous disposons
suffisamment de recul pour pouvoir en
dresser un bilan
ma demande formulée bien avant les
grèves de décembre n'a donc rien de
conjoncturel mais elle prouve bien
l'actualité permanente de cette question
première priorité de la loi le dialogue
social
l'accord de branche prévoyant la mise en
oeuvre d'une procédure de prévention des
conflits s'applique bien aux entreprises
de transports publics urbains
malheureusement s'agissant des
transports interurbains notamment
scolaires il n'a pas été possible
d'obtenir un accord et c'est un décret
qui a donc dû être promulguée il
s'agissait d'adopter des règles
d'organisation et de déroulement des
négociations afin d'éviter qu'un
différend aboutissent à un conflit et
comme le soulignait le rapport mandel
kern
en 2004 j'avais à l'époque beaucoup cité
la bonne grève est celle qui n'a pas
lieu parce que le dialogue la prévenue
la loi at elle permis d'éviter des
grèves
il semble que ce soit le cas si l'on
analyse les chiffres figurant au rapport
remis au parlement en octobre 2008
a la ratp le recours au dispositif de
prévention des conflits s'est concrétisé
par une augmentation du nombre d'alarmés
sociales de 25% au cours du premier
semestre par rapport à la moyenne des
cinq années précédentes
91 % de ces alarmes n'ont pas été
suivies par un préavis de grève
le nombre de préavis a été quatre fois
moins élevé qu'au cours des cinq
dernières années
a la sncf tous les préavis doivent
maintenant être précédée d'une demande
de concertation immédiate
il y a à peu près trois fois plus de ces
demandes
en 2008 il y a eu
qu'en 2007 leur nombre
quant à lui baissé de 30% et un sur deux
n'a pas occasionné de perturbations pour
la clientèle le dispositif mis en oeuvre
par la loi semble donc avoir un effet
positif sur la convivialité et vous nous
donnerez sans doute monsieur le ministre
des chiffres plus récents concernant
2009 puisque nous les avons pas je m'en
réjouis car la négociation doit précéder
l'action et non l inverse et la grève
n'est plus une fatalité
grâce à cette loi mais les rêves demeure
celle dont on parle parce qu'elle nous
touche nous les usagers absolument
étranger un conflit souvent interne qui
nous prend à témoin et nous prend en
otage
en cas d'échec de la procédure de
prévention des conflits la loi prévoyait
les modalités d'organisation de la
continuité du service
la déclaration préalable et
individuelles 48 heures à l'avancé de
l'intention de participer à une grève
qui s'applique au personnel
indispensable à l'exécution du service
est la pierre angulaire du dispositif
cette mesure permet de connaître
précisément le personnel gréviste et de
réaffecter les non grévistes sur les
lignes prioritaires
c'est elle qui permet à l'entreprise
d'informer à la vente les usagers sur
les horaires de passage à défaut d'avoir
tous leurs métros trains ou autobus
les français ne devrait plus attendre
sur un quai ou un trottoir un
hypothétique moyen de transport d'autant
que la loi prévoyait des plans de
transport adapté à l'importance de la
grève à la sncf les plans de transport
au niveau national sont approuvés par
l'état au niveau régional par les
régions et en ile-de-france par le stif
ainsi dans cette région le plan de
transport adapté transilien prend pour
référence les périodes de pointe 6h 9h
17h 20h et prévoit le même niveau
d'offre dans toutes les gares trois
niveaux de service sont prévues 60 50 33
% de l'offre de référence et il s'agit a
minima d'assurer un aller et retour dans
la journée
je regrette que seulement sept régions
en octobre 2008 et intégrer un tel plan
leur convention dix autres n'avaient pas
validé les plans ce qui a conduit les
préfets de région à se substituer à elle
le désengagement des régions souvent de
gauche puisqu'il y en a très peu de
droite à l'égard d'un système qui doit
faciliter le quotidien des habitants
sans remettre en question le droit de
grève est pour moi vraiment
incompréhensible
j'espère que les nouvelles assemblées
régionales de mars 2010 quelle qu'en
soit la couleur se préoccuperont
davantage des transports de leurs
concitoyens le député hervé mariton
dans son rapport sur l'application de
cette loi constat que lors des deux
grandes grèves les niveaux de deux
grandes grèves les niveaux de services
annoncés ont été globalement satisfait
le 22 mai 2008 journée de grève
nationale sur les retraites la sncf
assuré un service annoncée et 54 % des
usagers ont estimé que le service avait
été de meilleure qualité que les autres
jours de grève
le numéro vert national que la sncf
propose pendant ces jours a reçu en
moyenne plus de 26000 appels et les
numéros régionaux près de 10000 lors de
la grève interprofessionnelle du 29
janvier 2009 mais sncf a maintenu un
niveau de service supérieure à ce
qu'elle s'était engagée à garantir
l'information des usagers à laquelle
j'attache énormément d'importance s'est
mise en place avant le démarrage de la
grève par des moyens diversifiés tracts
d'information hangar site internet média
lorsque l'on connaît les difficultés de
communication de la sncf
on mesure mieux l'intérêt d'avoir rendu
obligatoire d'information en cas de
grève j'ajoute que lors de la grève
récente du mois dernier du rer a qui fut
la plus longue grève de transport depuis
95 alors que celle ci était très suivie
à 90 95 % je crois un train sur deux a
été maintenue aux heures de pointe selon
le créneau horaire défini par le stif
affirmé que la loi a prouvé son
efficacité à travers ces exemples va
choquer choqués les usagers qui ont
attendu dans le froid quasi polaire
des rer dans lequel il ne pouvait
parfois ne pas rentrer mais c'est aussi
prouvé qu'après deux ans d'application
il faut aller plus loin et tracer de
nouvelles perspectives tant dans leur
intérêt ce que dans l'aérien et le
maritime dans le transport terrestre de
voyageurs
la loi que les journalistes appellent à
tort ce service minimum et moi que
j'appelle comme d'autres services
garantie minimum est adapté au nombre de
grévistes elle n'empêche pas les grèves
dit pudiquement émotionnel déclenchée de
manière spontanée généralement en
réaction à l'agression d'un agent il n'y
a un an
c'est un anniversaire le 13 janvier 2009
à la gare saint lazare
celle-ci a été fermée suite à
l'agression d'un conducteur survenu le
jour précédent si l'on peut comprendre
l'émotion légitime des salariés lors là
lorsqu'un de leurs collègues est victime
de violence aussi inacceptable
qu'incompréhensible la grève est tout
aussi inacceptable et incompréhensible
pour les voyageurs surpris en cours de
journée qui ne peuvent rentrer chez eux
je n'oublie pas non plus ces mouvements
de solidarité parfois poussé à l'extrême
un agent agressé supposons dans un bus
au sud de paris peut provoquer un arrêt
de travail sur des lignes au nord ou à
l'est
sans oublier non plus cette grève du rer
b à la suite d'une fausse agression sur
un agent qui a bloqué les voyageurs
plusieurs jours a fait rater leur avion
à des centaines de passagers pour sept
ans 3 de la loi
monsieur le ministre je pense que le
gouvernement devrait inciter des
entreprises à élaborer avec les
organisations syndicales
une procédure applicable dans de telles
circonstances
afin d'apporter une réponse appropriée
et proportionnée à l'agression sans
entraîner une paralysie d'une partie
importante du trafic
le non respect de cette procédure
devrait pouvoir être sanctionné par
l'application de pénalités financières
aux salariés qui se mettent en grève
en dehors de tout cadre légal et
conventionnelle et que soit imposé aussi
un délai de 48 heures hormis pour les
personnes directement concernées par ce
droit de retrait le suggère aussi que de
nouvelles négociations soit entamée pour
prendre en compte les conditions
climatiques extrêmes lors des grèves
est il acceptable en dessous de zéro de
mettre en jeu la santé des usagers dans
le secteur ferroviaire
le problème auquel la loi n'a pas
répondu et celui des arrêts de travail à
répétition effectué le plus souvent au
moment de la prise de service et dont la
durée n'atteint jamais une heure je
laisserais mon collègue hugues portelli
évoqué la proposition de loi qu'il a
déposée au début de l'année 2009 je
présume en tout cas qu'ils valent évoqué
mais je pense que monsieur le ministre
nous fera savoir si la sncf a élaboré
une parade pour réduire l'impact de ces
arrêts de travail très perturbateurs sur
le trafic et sur les usagers dernières
limites de la loi elle ne paraît peine
ne permet pas de garantir un service
minimum en cas de grève massif de
personnel pour il pas l'un parvenir il
faudrait prévoir un véritable droit de
réquisition comme à l'hôpital solution
qui aurait été difficile à mettre en
oeuvre
alors moi je suggère une autre piste
comme par exemple l'obligation pour
l'entreprise de transport d'assurer un
service minimal de substitution
dans le cas où un conflit social se
prolongerait plus de 5 jours et perturbé
le trafic
ainsi dans les cas récents de grève de
la ratp ou de la sncf en région
parisienne ou à toulouse ou à lyon les
ans les transporteurs aurait pu louer
des autocars et amenées jusqu'aux gares
ou jusqu'aux portes des villes les
usagers vous nous direz donc monsieur le
ministre si l'horizon des usagers des
transports collectifs peu s'éclaircir
grâce à la concertation ou si vous
préférez laisser aux parlementaires la
voie libre à notre imagination que vous
avez pu mesurer pour faire avancer la
loi sur le service minimum garanti car
un moment où nous nous préoccupons de
développement durable il faudrait
peut-être aussi inventer des mesures
dissuasives
yves qui soit fondé sur la pollution
qu'engendrent ces grèves de transports
collectifs
un autre suggère qu'un acteur c'est
l'extension du dispositif de dialogue
social d'alerté d'information je dis
bien dialogue social alerte informations
aux transports maritimes et aériens
lors du débat de 2007 plusieurs de nos
collègues avaient souligné que la
desserte de certaines il pouvait être
interrompu en cas de conflit social
il avait souhaité que la loi soit
étendue aux liaisons maritimes
à l'époque le gouvernement avait répondu
qu'il n'était pas possible de légiférer
sur ce sujet avant d'avoir procédé une
concertation approfondie avec tous les
acteurs concernés et vérifier
l'efficacité du dispositif mis en place
le gouvernement a eu plus de deux ans le
parlement sur mon insistance et contre
l'avis du gouvernement certes avait
exigé qu'un rapport sur l'opportunité
d'étendre le service minimum aux autres
modes de transport public de voyageurs
soit remis avant le 1er mars 2008 près
de deux ans avant l'échéance près après
l'échéance prévue
le rapport ne nous avait toujours pas
été remis
et ce n'est pas faute de l'avoir
réclamée vous pouvez me faire confiance
estimant que la loi à améliorer la
situation
faute de réponse gouvernementale j'ai
pris l'initiative de déposer en juin
2009 une proposition de loi désormais co
signé à ce jour par plus de cinquante
sénateurs dont le président du groupe
ump gérard longuet qui vise à étendre
aux transports maritimes et aériens le
dispositif applicable au transport
terrestre c'est à dire le dialogue
social obligatoire
le préavis de grève la déclaration de 48
heures à l'avancé et l'information des
passagers auquel je tiens beaucoup
miracle du débat nous avons enfin reçu
hier ce rapport vous comprendrez que
pour moi c'est un peu difficile dans ce
court délai de l'analyser en détails
puisqu'il fait trente pages qu'il se
fonde sur les arguments juridiques
complexes alors que je réclame ce
rapport depuis un an et demi
j'apprécie peut le découvrir au dernier
moment alors le parcours en rapidement
j'ai cru comprendre mais je dis bien
j'ai cru comprendre je ne suis pas
juriste comme dans vos cabinets qu'il
explique que la loi serait inutile dans
le maritime
faute de conflit est difficilement
applicable dans l'aérien pour diverses
raisons
multiplicité des personnels intervenant
dans les conventions collectives et donc
les partenaires sociaux mais aussi
l'existence d'une concurrence qui ferait
échec à la notion de service public
s'agissant du maritime le rapport dit le
site
la situation actuelle monde que les
années 2008-2009 noms connus dans
l'ensemble que des perturbations
limitées du service public de transport
maritime de voyageurs
seule la corse a été affectée de
mouvements sociaux conduisant à des
arrêts prolongés de trafic
est ce une raison pour moi de ne pas
mettre en oeuvre la loi parce qu'il n'y
a pas de conflit ou peu de conflits ou
dans l'incertain demeure dans la
certains secteurs je pense toujours et
je le répète qu'il est préférable de
prévenir les conflits par une procédure
de dialogue organisée au préalable
s'agissant de l'aérien ce secteur selon
le rapport est ce que j'ai compris il ne
relèverait pas des obligations de
service public pour cause de
libéralisation des liaisons intra
communautaires et la loi ne pourrait
s'appliquer
je cite co liaison sous obligation de
service public et celles assurant la
continuité territoriale avec l'outre-mer
eh bien faisons la faisons le déjà pour
ces destinations
je rappelle que cette idée d'extension a
non seulement été votée dans la loi
d'août 2007 mais elle a été reprise par
un secrétaire d'état aux transports qui
s'appelle dominique bussereau qui fin
2007 lors d'une grève à air france avait
suggéré de mettre en place un meilleur
système d'alarmé sociale et indiqué que
le gouvernement étudierait la
possibilité d'étendre l'obligation de se
déclarer grévistes 48 heures avant le
déclenchement d'un conflit
j'ai toujours les coupures de presse
s'agissant des dispositions
communautaires qui ferait échec à
l'application de la notion de service
public
je serais allé me remarque suivante
d'abord rien n'empêche un état
imposer des obligations de service
public sur les services aériens
réguliers
si ces liaisons sont vitales ce que dit
les directives or il me semble que
plusieurs villes en france ne
connaissent pas de concurrence dans
l'aérien ne sont pas desservies par les
trains rapides
cette obligation de service public
pourrait donc j'ai concernés ensuite en
appliquant le raisonnement de votre
rapport sur l'aérien
on peut légitimement s'interroger sur
l'impact quant à l'ouverture à la
concurrence du transport ferroviaire
la réglementation du droit de grève qui
était introduit dans la loi sur le
service minimum garanti a été en effet
justifié par la nécessité d'assurer la
continuité du service public
mais alors si l'exploitation de
certaines lignes ferroviaires est
dorénavant assurée dans une logique
purement commerciale
est ce dire que la réglementation de la
grève et du service minimum perd sa
légitimité dans le service dans les
services ferroviaires je vous interroge
sur cette ambiguïté
en conclusion il me semble que la loi de
2007 a marqué une réelle avancée les
partisans du statu quo qui nous avait
expliqué qu'elle créerait plus de
difficultés qu'elle n'en résoudrait ou
qu'elle serait inapplicable ont été
démenties par les fêtes
la loi est correctement appliqué des
salariés ont compris la justification
les usagers en apprécient les avantages
qu'ils jugent cependant encore limitée
des progrès sont non seulement possible
mais aussi souhaitable si on a le souci
d'améliorer la situation des usagers ce
qui est mon cas et ma préoccupation
comme les déboires de leurs stars l'ont
montré récemment il arrive encore que
des passagers restent bloqués dans un
train pendant des heures en étant peu
informés de ce qui va arriver et sans
même recevoir un verre d'eau pourquoi le
principe de précaution ne s'imposeraient
t-il pas aux transporteurs en exigeant
qu'ils aient toujours suffisamment d'eau
pour les passagers en cas de retard
important il y à des personnes âgées il
y a des enfants
il n'y a aucun moyen si le dialogue
social doit être l'outil privilégié pour
réaliser ces nouvelles avancées
le parlement ne peut pas a priori écarté
d'éventuelles mesures législatives pour
inciter les uns et les autres à l'action
dans les autres secteurs du train
or si les négociations ne sont pas dans
l'année nos concitoyens ne
comprendraient pas que l'on refusé tant
le service minimum garanti alors qu'il
fait quand même à mon avis épreuve je ne
nie pas qu'il y ait sans doute des
difficultés juridiques
mais après tout c'est nous les
législateurs et j'estime que c'est à
nous de faire la loi et de faire évoluer
le droit
je souhaite donc que le débat de ce soir
nous permettent à la fois d'effectuer un
bilan de dégager de nouvelles pistes
pour l'avenir et d'essayer enfin de
préserver la liberté de chacun de
circuler et de travailler
ce qui me semble un peu oublié et
j'aimerais bien que la solution pour
régler ces problèmes ne soient pas que
technique comme par exemple multiplié
les métro entièrement automatique
ce qu'on vous fait conscience jour merci
chers collègues
la parole est à madame raymonde le
texier
s'il vous plaît madame
ici j'ai président au monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues élus dans
le val d'oise je suis entouré de
personnes dans le rer a est le moyen de
transport quotidien pour venir
travailler à paris mais s'il est vrai
que la grève récente leur a posé bien
des problèmes
leur exaspération avait cependant
d'autres sources
ce n'est pas l'exigence d'un service
minimum en cas de grève qu'il faisait
remonter mais la médiocre qualité du
service au quotidien
aujourd'hui les désagréments et certains
les plus courants subies par des usagers
ne sont pas dues à des grèves mais à des
dysfonctionnements techniques des
suppressions de trains du matériel à
bout de souffle et des infrastructures
surchargé c'est le sous-investissement
dans l'entretien des réseaux et du
matériel qui pose problème
la question de fond n'a rien à voir avec
l'instauration d'un service minimum
elle pose le problème des moyens dégagés
par l'état les entreprises de transport
pour faire fonctionner dans de bonnes
conditions
les transports publics terrestres du
voyageur ce sont donc une fois de plus
les priorités budgétaires du
gouvernement qui sont au coeur du
problème
faute d'investissements de l'état depuis
des années la région a hérité en 2006
d'un réseau arrivé à saturation est
incapable de répondre à la demande
croissante
elle a lancé un programme de
renouvellement des matériels et
d'ouverture de renforcement ou de
prolongation de nouvelles lignes qu'elle
assume seul sans aucun soutien de l'état
le gouvernement a refusé en 2006 d'aider
la région à renouveler le matériel
roulant afin de transférer à un type
sain son objectif se réduisant à se
débarrasser de charges lourdes et de
problèmes de gestion à court terme
dans le même ordre d'idée rappelons si
qui n'a pas tenu les engagements du
contrat signé entre l'état et la région
bloquant ainsi plusieurs projets de
transport appelons également
que l'état a refusé de s'associer à la
réalisation du plan de modernisation des
transports en ile de france alors qu'ils
ne lui ai pas demandé de financement
supplémentaire mais l'attribution de
ressources nouvelles comme par exemple
l'augmentation du versement transport
taxe payée par les entreprises
le reversement du farif où le produit la
taxation des plus values foncières ou
immobilières
rappelons toujours que la décision du
gouvernement de transférer l'intégralité
du patrimoine du stif à la ratp laisse
le stif sans aucun actif donc sans
patrimoine propre lui permettant
d'emprunter un vrai coup porté à la
capacité d'investir pour l'avenir
et pendant que la région on mute pour
faire face aux besoins du présent et
anticiper l'avenir l'état se lancent
dans des projets pharaoniques
la ligne de métro prévue dans le cadre
du grand paris coûtera 21 milliards aux
contribuables
une somme qui permettrait de résoudre
les problèmes actuels transports
ferroviaires en ile de france et de
financer de nouveaux projets et le
gouvernement exclut les collectivités
locales et les usagers du choix du tracé
privilégie un aménagement qui ne répond
en rien aux besoins quotidiens des
usagers actuels et met en place un
système de transport à deux vitesses
d'un côté un réseau à destination des
populations qui faute de moyens
continuent à se dégrader et de l'autre
un tgv urbain destiné à une clientèle de
privilégiés cerise sur le gâteau c'est
21 milliard ne sont bien sûr pas
financer les collectivités locales
devront donc en prendre à leur charge
une grande partie l'état refusant de les
associer aux prises de décisions mais
n'ayant aucun scrupule à siphonner leurs
moyens on voit bien réduire la
problématique des transports à la seule
question de la mise en place d'un
service minimum relève de l'imposture
le débat sur le service minimum vie
surtout
a suscité la polémique sur l'exercice du
droit de grève
pour mieux éviter tout débat sur
l'organisation du transport ferroviaire
en ile de france
en outre la notion de service minimum
qui dans le fait se réduit à un service
restreint permet surtout aux entreprises
de transport ici la ratp la sncf de
s'exonérer de tout remboursement des
titres de transport ou de mise en place
de diminution des tarifs pour mon
service rendu voilà pourquoi malgré la
demande insistante de du président de la
région ile de france jean paul huchon
aucune modification tarifaire prenant en
compte la gemme considérables subis par
les usagers est intervenue après la
grève du rer a
c'est encourager la l'irresponsabilité
de l'entreprise on peut même se demander
si cette irresponsabilité organisé de
l'entreprise ne sert pas des manoeuvres
politiciennes alors que les élections
régionales se profilent quelle aubaine
pour les ministres candidats du critiqué
la gestion de la crise par le président
de région alors que comme l'écrit dans
son rapport de février 2009
le député ump hervé mariton la vitalité
du dialogue social est à l'évidence du
ressort du management de la sncf on ne
saurait être plus clair
c'est également la précision qu'on voulu
apporter l'ensemble des présidents de
région au moment de l'instauration du
service 10 minimum je les cite la
gestion du service de transports relève
des entreprises de transport de même que
ces entreprises sont seuls responsables
du dialogue social avec leurs salariés
rendre les élus responsables des
conséquences fâcheuses pour les usagers
du mauvais climat social susceptible de
régner dans des entreprises de transport
sont redonné le pouvoir d'intervenir
dans leur management est une aberration
la contrepartie de la liberté d'action
de l'entreprise doit être sain
responsabilise
et dans le cas de la grève du rer pas de
décembre on tient le parfait
contre-exemple les critiques des
ministres candidats sont non seulement
injuste mais elles témoignent au mieux
de l'ignorance des sujets sur lesquels
ils s'expriment ou pire une criante
malhonnêteté intellectuelle
à moins qu'ils nous unissent les deux
dans un d'électoralisme jeu commentaire
supplémentaire leur mise en cause est
d'autant plus dérisoires que
l'instauration la véritable service
minimum vise à assurer une circulation
quasi normale aux heures de pointe dans
les grandes agglomérations
or pour que cela soit possible il faut
que 70 à 75 % des agents soient présents
autrement dit que la grève soit un échec
il se trouve que si la grève est chou le
service est de fait assurée et le
problème ne se pose plus une fois de
plus la loi et le discours sur le
service minimum se résume à une parole
aussi un contact warcq inopérante pour
les usagers en plus des difficultés
rencontrées le champ tivement d'avoir
été manipulé par un gouvernement qui
leur vend des ags des engagements qui
sait pertinemment de pouvoir tenir
devient détestable
alors pour ne pas avoir à assumer les
effets désastreux de loi inefficace et
impossible à mettre en oeuvre la droite
se met en quête de boucs émissaires
ce seront donc les collectivités
territoriales en tant qu' autorité
organisatrice de transport qui seront
désignés alors qu'elles n'ont pas la
maîtrise de la situation puisque l'issue
finale dépendra du nombre de grévistes
de l'entreprise de transport
à moins de donner aux collectivités
locales l'autorité directe sur ces
entreprises ministre candidat à leur
coach présidentielle devrait par respect
pour les usagers cesser
d'instrumentaliser des situations
douloureuses pour servir des causes
douteuses
c'est également l'avis du bureau
international du travail
celui ci a déclaré la loi non conforme à
la convention numéro 87 de l'oit et sur
la liberté syndicale et la protection du
droit syndical
selon le bit et la fixation d'un service
minimum négocié devrait être limitée aux
opérations strictement nécessaires pour
que la satisfaction des besoins de base
de la population ou des exigences
minimales du service soit assurée car
elle limite
l'un des moyens de pression essentiels
dont dispose des travailleurs pour
défendre leurs intérêts économiques et
sociaux
fin de citation dubé it et le bit et
souligne que les organisations de
travailleurs devraient pouvoir si elles
le souhaitent participer à la définition
de ce service minimum comme les
employeurs et les pouvoirs publics
en conséquence le bit et demandé au
gouvernement français d'amender la loi
dans ce sens
mais comme cette loi n'avait vocation
que faire du buzz et non à instaurer un
véritable dialogue au sein d'entreprises
ou à accorder une place au dialogue
entreprises usagers gageons que les
recommandations du bit et n'intègrent
rompt pas rapidement la liste des
urgences gouvernementale aujourd'hui la
grève du rer a est terminée pourtant et
des agréments continue pour les usagers
temps de déplacement rallonger retards
et suppressions de trains panne arriver
à l'heure au travail sans prévoir des
marges allant de 30 à 45 minutes pour
des trajets d'environ trois heures
aller-retour est encore risqué
les problèmes de fonds d'infrastructures
d'équipements de conditions de travail
de salaire de sécurité et surtout
l'ouverture à la concurrence et de
qualité du management dans le complexe
libéral d'ouverture à la concurrence
sont toujours là le service minimum dans
ces conditions et qu'un rideau de fumée
il consiste
prétendre que les difficultés
rencontrées par les usagers sont le fait
de salariés irresponsable est
privilégiée il permet surtout au
gouvernement et à l'entreprise
décisionnaires et de ses responsabilités
et de ne pas agir sur l'état du réseau
son entretien et sa mise en sécurité
vous le voyez mes chers collègues le
groupe socialiste n'est pas vraiment
dupe de telles manoeuvres
mais aucun de vous non plus n'est ce pas
qui vaut mercier votre attention je vous
remercie chaque élève la parole est au
président yvon collin
monsieur le président ce ministre mes
chers collègues
peu de temps après la dernière élection
présidentielle le parlement a adopté le
projet de loi sur le dialogue social et
la continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres réguliers de
voyageurs
cette voie devait poursuivre deux
objectifs d'une part prévenir le plus
efficacement possible les conflits
sociaux dans les transports terrestres
et ferroviaires par le dialogue social
et d'autre part de garantir en cas de
grève un service réduit mais connus par
avance des usagers en répondant à leurs
besoins prioritaires
ce texte a tenté de trouver un équilibre
entre plusieurs principes dont la
liberté d'aller et venir l'accès aux
services publics leur esprit de 3 de
crêpes
ce texte a vocation à tenir compte du
droit élémentaire de contester des
conditions de travail sans porter
atteinte aux droits de nos concitoyens
de pouvoir circuler librement et sans
entraves majeures pour cela il vise à
assurer la continuité du service public
essentiel pour les déplacements
quotidiens
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre arrive
l'heure du bilan
selon l'ensemble des entreprises
concernées notamment la sncf et la ratp
la loi a eu un impact plutôt positif sur
le dialogue social
elles en premier lieu renforcer les
acquis des accords préalablement comme
plus entre les partenaires sociaux au
sein des deux entreprises et en second
lieu elle a eu un impact globalement
positif sur le service assure aux
usagers je me permettrai de souligner à
ce propos monsieur le ministre que dans
certaines interconnexion de la région
parisienne
le service et parfois il paradoxalement
mieux assurés en période de grève où les
trains de réserves sont à l'heure qu'en
période normale où il devient de plus en
plus difficile de prendre un train qui
soit conforme aux horaires indiqués
le nombre de journées perdues est
sincère pour raison de grève est au plus
bas depuis quatre ans à la ratp en 2008
sur 3 1051 agents tenus de faire part de
leur intention de faire grève seuls 63
n'ont pas respecté d'amour ces données
sont encourageantes mais il ne faudrait
pas sous-estimer
les différences d'application de la loi
entre les collectivités et plus
largement entre les territoires
le bilan globalement positif selon la
formule consacrée ne signifie ne
signifie pas que tout aille bien
certaines limites de la loi sont
inhérentes au droit de grève
trois garanties par notre constitution
et qu'il s'agit bien entendu en aucun
cas et qu'une façon de remettre en cause
par exemple en cas de grève massive
d'une catégorie de personnel aucun
service ne peut plus être assuré
et pour cela il faudrait faire appel au
droit de réquisition qui nous le savons
n'entre pas dans les prérogatives
dévolues aux pouvoirs publics par la loi
de 2007
en outre la loi ne prévoit aucun
dispositif dans le cas de grève illégale
et n'a pas non plus pour ambition de
régler les questions de l'iliade et
insuffisante investissements dont on le
sait monsieur le ministre quelles sont
la principale cause de la vétusté des
infrastructures et du matériel roulant à
cause de ces insuffisances des voyageurs
se retrouvent soumis malgré eux aux
caprices du temps chaque saison et cause
de retards voire d'annulation de trafic
l'hiver nos matériels ne résiste pas au
froid
elle était à la canicule ce débat montre
bien qu'en dehors des questions
d'organisation et de fonctionnement
apparaît une fois de plus le problème
récurrent de la capacité des entreprises
publiques à financer l'investissement
mais aussi d'innovations
c'est aussi en partie de la
responsabilité de l'état
il faut le dire et je tiens à cet égard
a souligné que si les services des ter
des trains express régionaux ou du
transilien en ile de france sont
perturbés ralenti voire a été sur
certaines lignes
la raison année le plus souvent allé dû
à l'état du réseau dont l'audit réalisé
en 2005 avait révélé que 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires par an était
nécessaire pour le régénérer or pour
développer un service de qualité en
matière de transports les collectivités
tri territoriales qui finance il faut
quand même le ajouté le rappeler 80% du
système sont déjà très largement
mises à contribution aujourd'hui les
régions soit même amené à se substituer
à l'état pour entretenir le réseau ferré
national
et à ce sujet soulignant que la région
midi pyrénées n'est pas en reste et est
d'ailleurs sur ce point les mêmes en
pointe
en fait se pose aussi la question des
détournements de la loi notamment par le
biais des grèves de courte durée celle
ci ne cessent de se multiplier
nous l'avons duré seulement lors
d'événements qui ont été rappelés en
garde c lazar et qui rendent difficile
voire impossible la prévisibilité du
trafic lorsqu'il ya alternance de grève
de 24 heures et de grève de courte durée
pour améliorer les dispositifs a donc
adopté en 2007
je ne pense pas que recourir à une
nouvelle loi sur la meilleure des
solutions
le dialogue entre les parties avaient
déjà porté ses fruits doit être
poursuivi monsieur le ministre si vous
êtes attachés comme moi à la continuité
du service public du service collectif
il est urgent que vous donnez aux
entreprises publiques les moyens de
financer de régénérer les réseaux ferrés
et de mettre à disposition des voyageurs
des équipements en bon état de marche
ce qui évitera bien des perturbations
puisque la plupart d'entre elles je le
répète souliers à l'obsolescence des
voix et des matériels depuis 20 ans la
société française a beaucoup évolué et
les usagers des services publics de
transport sont devenus de plus en plus
des clients ils attendent la même
qualité de service que celle qu'ils
exigent d'une entreprise privée sachant
par ailleurs qu'il finance d entreprise
par l'impôt il n'en semblent de ce fait
que plus exigeants le sentiment de
dépendance et d'incertitude face aux
incidents et nouvelles informations en
train des critiques souvent vives envers
les entreprises de transports publics
enfin grâce au rôle majeur comme si aux
autorités organisatrices c'est-à-dire
aux collectivités locales
les décisions doivent être davantage
prises plus près des citoyens et sous
leur contrôle
un dialogue depuis francs doit être
entamée à des organismes syndicaux qui
comprenne je crois à la nécessité de
participer aux transformations de la
société dans le secteur des transports
je ne doute pas que cela renforcera leur
représentativité au sein des salariés
les cas sont également des citoyennes et
des usagers des services
publique monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues tout débat sur le service
minimum dans les transports qui
commencerait en opposant entre les
catégories les deux catégories que sont
les salariés les usagers serez-vous est
me semble-t-il à l'échec est aujourd'hui
évident de la loi sur le service minimum
dans les transports ne règle pas tout
loin s'en faut
on suit aussi avant même de reprendre ce
chantier de revoir le dispositif en
vigueur faire preuve de sagesse et de
mesure est un préalable qui me semble
essentiel je vous remercie de votre
attention je vous remercie chers
collègues que la parole est à me
supporter lee
monsieur le président mais monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues voudraient
d'abord commencé ma petite intervention
par deux excellents citations dont l'une
de vous et une autre de votre collègue
monsieur woerth ministre du budget
mozilla fonction publique qui ont été
prononcés à l'occasion de l'une des plus
belles grève des transports ces derniers
temps vous aviez dit vous même votre
grève particulièrement bien suivi jeu si
il y en effet un problème c'est que la
loi sur le service minimum ne fonctionne
pas lorsque tout le monde est en grève
voilà et j'ajouterai une autre citation
de monsieur woerth un peu plus précise
qui va me convient bien
le service minimum a très bien
fonctionné jusqu'à présent notamment la
sncf
maintenant quand il ya un conflit de
cette nature et quand tous les
conducteurs sont en grève
il est difficile de l'appliquer car il
n'y a pas de réquisition tout est dit
alors madame progresser a très bien
expliqué ce qui était le sens de la loi
du 21 août 2007 qui était un loi sur le
service garanti en cas de grève et non
pas une loi sur le service minimum
puisque vous nous avez demandé
instamment nous avons été 80 ici à voter
malgré tout la demande d'un vrai service
minimum le gouvernement à l'époque
c'était pas vous c'est monsieur bertrand
nous avait dit non non je ne veux pas
entendre parler de service minimum était
clair vous l'avez dit
donc il ne s'était pas une loi sur le
service minimum on nous avait demandé de
ne pas voter une nous avait demandé de
voter une loi sur le dialogue social
dans les transports dans les transports
publics terrestres
donc on avait restreint restreint
restreint et il en est sorti cette loi
alors qu'est ce qu'elle a donné sept
jours appelle les deux premiers volets
de la loi c'était une part l'obligation
donc de la négociation préalable avant
tout dépôt de préavis de grève
et puis le deuxième aspect c'était la
mise en oeuvre d'un service garanti en
cas de grève ou de perturbations
prévisibles les transports publics mais
la loi n'avait pas retenu une définition
uniforme du service minimum
elle avait laissé les autorités
organisatrices des transports aux
autorités donc le soin de définir les
desserts prioritaires en fonction des
spécificités locales et le texte
prévoyait par ailleurs l'obligation pour
les ald
larié de déclarer deux jours avant le
début de la grève s'ils devaient s'ils
entendaient participer ou non à la digue
et le prévoyait et éventuellement après
huit jours de grève
la consultation des salariés à bulletin
secret sous la poursuite de celle ci
soit l'initiative d'employeurs ou à la
demande d'une organisation syndicale
représentative
alors qu'est ce qu'il en a été de ses
deux premiers volets donc on parle du
troisième sur l'information la déviation
des âges et les goûters le problème
essentiellement c'est celui du dialogue
social et moi personnellement et pas mal
de mes collègues nous posons des
questions à propos de la notion de
dialogue social à la sncf ou la ratp
quel dialogue social petit y avoir
lorsque la représentation syndicale et
balkaniser en de multiples organisations
qui sont divisés en permanence soit par
des raisons idéologiques soit par des
oppositions catégorielles entre les
conducteurs les contrôleurs et c'est
quel dialogue social peut-il y avoir
lorsque certains responsables syndicaux
avoue benoîtement que la prolongation de
la grève récent du rer a était en partie
motivé par la surenchère syndicale à la
veille d'élections professionnelles
quel dialogue social peut-il y avoir
lorsqu'une partie des suppressions ou
des retards de trains en dehors de tout
mouvement social déclarer collectif est
due selon la formule que nous entendons
le plus souvent de plus en plus souvent
quand on attend tranquillement sur les
quais un très hypothétique pour arriver
et du jeu si tu as des équipages nom
complet comme si on était dans un avion
1 et c'est à dire que tout simplement il
ya une partie du personnel qui ne s'est
pas rendue au travail à l'heure prévue
donc là c'est pas la grève ou le
dialogue social c'est une partie du
personnel qui ne travaillent pas et cela
de façon perlé et régulière
quel dialogue social peut-il y avoir
s'il n'y a pas de bonne foi réciproque
de part et d'autre il faut que cette
bonne foi soit partagée lorsque par
exemple la grève de la gare saint lazare
a montré que le droit de grève pouvait
être manipulé en jouant sur le calcul
horaires de l'arrêt de travail vers est
évident que là on se trouve dans un cas
de non respect du principe de bonne foi
élémentaire alors vous savez monsieur le
ministre que nous avons déposés à
plusieurs ici il ya pas mal de temps une
proposition de loi pour mettre fin aux
grèves de 59 minutes - par un calcul
différent de l'arrêt de travail
et donc nous voulons savoir si ce type
de proposition de loi est susceptible un
jour d'être regardée avec intérêt par le
gouvernement dans le cadre du dialogue
social entre lui-même et sa majorité
parlementaire
alors j'attends que le troisième volet
de la loi qui porte sur l'information
des usagers et le remboursement des
titres de transport alors je dois dire
souvent de villa la formation est
assurée correctement quand je vous
dirais que dans ma gars que je prends
tous les jours ça fait à peu près un
mois et demi que les télévisions sont en
panne et qu'on n'a toujours pas afficher
les heures des trains qui passent et si
les trains passeront effectivement un
jour et donc correctement
c'est vrai quand on prend les sites
internet quand on va sur abcdtrains ou
sur le site du francilien
on sait à peu près à quoi s'en tenir
donc voilà veille au soir on va en
rentrant du travail
regardez les sites pour voir ce qui nous
attend lendemain matin par contre en
matière de remboursement
très franchement je vois que la loi
n'est pas appliquée à mon souvenir dans
la région parisienne elle a dû être
appliqué une fois une seule fois et elle
a été appliquée pour un mouvement social
qui étaient longs massifs etc
mais quand vous avez un problème du type
de celui que moi il m'arrive tous les
matins c'est à dire que vous avez des
trains supprimés ou des trains qui
arrivent en retard et que bien vous êtes
obligé de partir avec trois trains
avance pour être sûr d'arriver à
attendre dans votre enfui pour faire
votre cours ce n'est pas normal
bon moi je ne me plains pas j'ai les
moyens de me débrouiller mais le
travailleur de base qui prend le train
qui a pas d'autre moyen de transport qui
sait que l'autoroute a15 ou la 115 et
saturent à partir de 6h30 du matin et
qui est condamné et captifs qui est
obligé pour le transport collectif et
qui sait que maintenant les employeurs
répugnent à prendre des dessins marié
qui vais habite dans le val d'oise
parce qu'ils savent qu'il ya de bonnes
chances qu'ils arrivent en retard à leur
travail et bien honnêtement je vous
dirais que ça ce n'est pas indemnisables
c'est un vrai problème c'est un problème
qui fait que finalement pas mal de gens
dans ma région ce livre vaut mieux que
j'aille habiter ailleurs parce que
j'aurai plus de facilités pour trouver
du travail que si je continue à
fonctionner en utilisant des transports
aussi dégradée alors moi j'en arrive
à au dernier point qui est pas dans la
loi mais qui comme le disait tout à
l'heure catherine prolonger un peu le
débat que qui est celui là qu'on doit
avoir aujourd'hui c'est pas simplement
la question du dialogue social ces du
thé gré mais c'est le reste moi je
partage en partie la vide de madame le
texier sur le fait que les
investissements sont insuffisants dans
les transports collectifs qui concerne
la grimentz majorité de la population
mais c'est vrai que nous ne sommes plus
intéressés à voir des trains de banlieue
qui fonctionne correctement que des
lignes de tgv supplémentaires que ne
prendront qu'une certaine catégorie de
personnes
donc les investissements pendant très
longtemps on était insuffisant de la
part de l'état c'est vrai mais moi
j'ajouterais madame le texier que ça
continue aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que peut-être que la
région par exemple celle que je connais
ile-de-france a commencé à investir mais
le problème c'est que ces
investissements à mon humble avis
d'usagé sont erronées un exemple quand
on vous dit dans quelques temps vous
allez avoir des bombardiers quand vous
savez que c'est bombardier ils ont une
caractéristique ils n'ont qu'à laitages
et que dans plus au lieu de passer
toutes les 7000 aux heures de pointe ils
passeront toutes les 14 minutes
eh bien vous aurez des trains plus
petits qui passeront moins souvent
est-ce qu'on va régler le problème du
service public avec des trains de ce
genre au jeu répond non ça s'arrangera
pas on aura peut-être des trains qui
tomberont moins souvent en panne
mais comme ils seront plus petits qu'ils
arriveront moins souvent et bien le
problème ne sera pas grève régler leurs
problèmes aussi qu'on a un fréquemment
sur les transports de ce genre c'est
tout les les dysfonctionnements au
quotidien un exemple les sanctions du
stif
quand le stif sanctionne les trains qui
arrivent en retard tout fait la sncf
eh bien les trains ne s'arrêtent pas ll
prêt à l'autoriser tran pas s'arrêter en
gare qui fait que le train arrive à
l'heure à la gare du nord ou à la gare
saint lazare
mais évidemment comme il n'a pas pris
les voyageurs le problème c'est que le
service public n'a pas fonctionné alors
si la solution pour faire arriver les
trains à l'heure c'est de ne pas prendre
2 2
d'usagé et bien c'est un talent hors jeu
sont cumulés proposition de certains de
mes collègues qui sont supprimés les
conducteurs est celle de steve qui est
supprimé les arrêtera bien le jour où il
y aura ni usagers ni conducteur je pense
qu'en effet le problème du service
public des transports en région
ile-de-france en tout cas sera réglé
merci je remercie sûr que l'aig
la parole est à madame mireille
cherchent s'il vous plaît
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le service minimum est
un serpent de mer brandit régulièrement
comme une solution dysfonctionnement des
services publics qu'ils touchent aux
transports ou à l'éducation nationale
cela permet en effet pour ces
pourfendeurs de faire rapidement
l'impasse sur les véritables maux dont
souffrent les services publics c'est à
dire le sous financement chronique et le
désengagement de l'état tout en pointant
du doigt les agents du secteur public
dont le statut est vécue comme une
hérésie pas votre gouvernement monsieur
le ministre
en préalable de ce départ souhaiterait
donc formulé une simple préconisations
méfions nous des amalgames et gardons à
l'esprit qu'une démocratie ne peut sans
se dénaturer portée d atteinte
disproportionnée au droit de grève
moyen d'exercices fondateur de toute
citoyenneté l'ordre du jour nous conduit
à la demande du groupe ump à faire le
bilan de la loi sur le service minimum
dans les transports
il faut dire que l'actualité nous y
invite regardez grèce qui ont touché la
ligne a du rer en ile de france en
décembre
ces mouvements sociaux ont participé à
la démonstration de line et fuck
l'inefficacité de cette loi et ce malgré
les déclarations nicolas sarkozy qui
considère à l'instauration du service
minimum comme un succès personnel sur la
forme comment ne pas voir dans cette
initiative du groupe ump à l'instar des
déclarations de sa candidate en ile de
france
une démarche politicienne alors même que
la campagne des élections régionales bat
son plein en effet la candidate valérie
pécresse prend appui sur ce conflit le
conflit du rer pour porter ses attaques
contre la majorité sortante accusant
notamment le président du champ de
mettre de l'huile sur le feu et de
parasiter les débats en demandant la
nomination d'un médiateur
mais c'est le comble de la démagogie
alors même qu'il s'agit simplement de
l'application de l'article 6 de la loi
de 2007 qualifiées sur tous les bancs
comme une avancée
en termes de dialogue social nomination
d'un médiateur
elle a également estimé madame valérie
pécresse sans autre forme de procès
qu'il aurait pu apporter un peu plus au
service minimum en finançant par exemple
des bus de nuit permet permettez nous de
lui rappeler qu'elle oublie un peu vite
que la décentralisation de la compétence
liée au transport de l'état aux régions
s'est faite sans les moyens adéquat
ainsi vous ne pouvez sans faire preuve
de mauvaise foi discréditer les efforts
des autorités organisatrices que sont
les régions qui offre au quotidien un
service public de transport en commun de
qualité
elles ont investi des millions d'euros
pour pallier au désengagement de l'état
et garantir un véritable droit à la
mobilité
c'est ainsi notamment que si la
proportion des ralentissements sur les
voies en termes de transport de
voyageurs a été réduite
c'est quasi uniquement grâce aux
investissements des régions et la
première d'entre elles en effet la
région midi pyrénées depuis ce de plus
il est étonnant de voir que vous
qualifiez aujourd'hui cette loi du 21
août 2007 de loi relative au service
minimum alors même que lors de son
adoption
elle portait quand même le nom le nom de
loi sur le dialogue social et continuité
du service public des transports
terrestres le choix des mots nous donne
là aussi clairement une indication sur
l'objectif profond dans l'instauration
d'un service minimum celui de limiter le
droit de grève et non de porter
l'exigence d'une modernisation du
dialogue social
nous craignons que ce débat dont
l'objectif affiché réside dans
l'élaboration d'un bilan sur la loi de
2007 ne servent au final de ballon
d'essai pour tester la mise en oeuvre de
dispositions encore plus régressives
sans autre considération
comme je viens de l'évoquer les récentes
grèves ont démontré l'inefficacité du
dispositif adopté à ce titre je vous
rappelle que les partenaires sociaux
avaient unanimement rejeté ces
dispositions et qu'il continue de penser
que le dialogue social n'a pas connu de
véritable amélioration
j'attends monsieur le ministre que vous
me disiez le contraire je pense alors
que le bilan engagé doit comporter un
volet sur le dialogue social et non
seulement porté sur le service minimum
en tant que tel pour notre part nous
avions regretté le caractère polémique
d'une telle loi
kirène le rien ni en faveur du dialogue
social ni concernant la continuité du
service public
ceci pour différentes raisons
premièrement l'impératif de continuité
du service public ne peut se penser
uniquement en temps de grève
cela a été dit à plusieurs reprises par
les orateurs précédents
or pour les usagers c'est tous les jours
la galère en effet l'écrasante majorité
des perturbations quotidiennes subies
par les usagers est imputable non aux
grèves mais aux défaillances du perse du
matériel roulant aux insuffisances des
moyens humains financiers et des
capacités d'infrastructure qui
provoquent des incidents des accidents
la suppression de services de dessert
des retards bref la loi ne répond à
aucune de ses préoccupations
deuxièmement concernant le dialogue
social
rien ne sert de traiter les conséquences
de la conflictuelle it et au sein des
entreprises de transport si
parallèlement rien n'est fait pour
éviter les causes de ce conflit
le service minimum ça par an ainsi un
emplâtre sur une jambe de bois
d'une part malgré la décision rendue par
le conseil constitutionnel nous
continuons de penser que les atteintes
portées au droit de grève par cette loi
sont disproportionnées
modifier l'essence même de ce droit en
effet le droit de grève est un droit
individuel qui s'exerce collectivement
ce que remet en cause l'article 5 de la
loi d'août 2007
en effet la déclaration individuelle de
grève contribuer à désolidariser les
salariés en les rappelant un lien
hiérarchique
ceci reste inacceptable et contraire à
la jurisprudence de la cour de cassation
qui estime qu'il ne peut être imposé à
un salarié d'indiquer à son employeur
avant le déclenchement d'une grève
qu'ils participent au mouvement
d'autre part que nous considérons qu
imposer une négociation préalable de
huit jours s'ajoutant cinq jours du
préavis revient à soumettre la légalité
du droit de grève à une condition
supplémentaire restreignant ses
conditions d'exercice
à ce titre comment ne pas voir que le
préavis du préavis n'a été utilisée par
la direction comme le moyen d'en dit
d'enliser les débats et n'a pas permis
une amélioration du dialogue social la
seule disposition favorable figure à
l'article 12 inséré grâce à un
amendement de mon groupe qui stipule que
les autorités organisatrices de
transport incorpore dans les conventions
qu'elle conclue avec les entreprises de
transport des critères sociaux et
environnementaux de qualité de service
nous estimons qu'il s'agit là d'une
mesure de nature à diminuer la
conflictuelle it et au sein des
entreprises de transport et nous
regrettons que sur ce point nous n'ayons
aucun élément de bilan mais monsieur le
ministre vous allez sans doute nous en
donner je ne reviendrai pas ici sur la
provocation de l'article 10 qui
stigmatise encore un peu plus ses agents
de transport en rappelant le principe de
non paiement des jours de grève
laissant entendre en creux que les
grèves sont sans incidence financière
sur les agents du service public c'est
que c'est totalement inacceptable
les premières victimes économiques des
graisses sont les grévistes je crois
qu'il est important ici de le rappeler
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du bilan sur
l'application de cette loi gendre est
que nous ayons clairement manqué
d'éléments pour préparer ce débat
monsieur lui
istres faut d'un bilan gouvernemental ou
des entreprises de transports fo
d'auditions menées par la commission des
affaires économiques au sénat nous avons
uniquement pu nous appuyer sur des
rapports d'information certes de qualité
réalisées en début d'année 2009 par le
député mariton et les députés bono et
kossowski sur le fond si les deux
rapports se retrouve sur un bilan
positif en ce qui concerne la formation
des usagers leurs préconisations sont
radicalement différentes
alors que le premier n'en ligne de mire
que la restriction absolu du droit de
grève
le second à juste titre souligne la
nécessité de renforcer le dialogue
social notamment grâce à la mise en
oeuvre d'un observatoire des relations
sociales par une meilleure démocratie
sociale au sein des entreprises
ferroviaires ainsi que par une meilleure
intégration dans ces instants des
représentants des usagers
nous approuvons ses propositions a
contrario nous estimons que le rapport
du député mariton loin de porter un
bilan sur les dispositions existantes
notamment en termes de dialogue social a
pour unique objectif de préconiser de
nouvelles dispositions particulièrement
dangereuse alors même que les
précédentes n'ont pas fait preuve de
leur utilité
qu'il s'agisse de portée à 72 heures le
délai de la déclaration individuelle de
grève qu'il s'agisse d'interdire le
dépôt d'un préavis pour des motifs de
même objet avant l'expiration du préavis
précédent au bien encore qu'il s'agisse
pour lutter contre les grèves de 59
minutes de renforcer les sanctions
financières à l'encontre des grévistes
en portant la retenue sur salaire à 1
50e du traitement pour le deuxième arrêt
de service et des suivants relatifs à la
même déclaration d'intention toutes ces
compositions ne concerne ni le dialogue
social ni la continuité du service
puisque comme le reconnaît le rapporteur
les grèves de 59 minutes ne sont pas
insurmontables dans l'organisation du
service par les entreprises nous
regrettons al'inverse l'absence de bilan
sur l'amélioration du dialogue social
monsieur le ministre vous allez aussi
nous le nous les préciser durant le pré
10 voir le préavis dupré asie ainsi que
l'absence d' analyse sur le fait que
seuls les salariés d'iss posées dans
cette loi d'obligations et non les
directions d'entreprise peut peut-être
serait-il temps de penser des
dispositions contraignantes en terme de
10 de dialogue social pour les
directions des entreprises de transport
parallèlement des parlementaires sans
attendre ces travaux d'analysé ont
déposé des propositions de loi qui ne
vise qu'à une restriction abusif du
droit de grève
ces propositions visent toutes à un
élargissement du service minimum que ce
soit par son domaine d'indication en
l'étendant transport maritime n'allait
rien madame procast ya que ce soit en
sanctionnant financièrement de manière
disproportionnée les grévistes
proposition de monsieur portelli je note
ici que cette proposition et 6 est très
sévère et compris par le député marie
tôt enfin la dernière mais également la
plus dangereuse celle du député ciotat
visant à permettre la réquisition de
personnels je vous rappelle alors
puisque cette idée a l'air de séduire un
certain nombre de nos collègues que la
réquisition sous réserve de quelques
dérogations très limitées hâtivement
énuméré contraire à un exercice normal
du droit de grève
la jurisprudence temps administratif que
judiciaire ne reconnaît lusage de
réquisition uniquement lorsqu'il est
question de sécurité publique
cette proposition de loi préconise
également la réalisation par les
entreprises d'une liste d'agents
volontaires pour suppléer les collègues
en tas de rêve
il s'agit là d'une proposition qui me
semble tout juste hallucinante temps
elle conduirait des agences privées par
avance d'un droit inaliénable qui est
constitutionnellement reconnu le droit
de crème sur le fond alors que cette
question devait être au coeur de ces
débats et du bilan de l'application de
cette loi nous regrettons que la
dimension du dialogue social soit à ce
point marginalisés il y a pourtant là
une marge de manoeuvre importante pour
limiter la config tu as lité au sein des
entreprises
objectif reconnu du service minimum
puisque les grèves sont la conséquence
directe soit de la dégradation du
dialogue social soit des politiques
menées tant par le goût
ernement que par les directions
d'entreprise de casse de l'emploi ou de
l'outil de production
ainsi il ne faut pas se leurrer tant que
la sncf mettra en oeuvre une politique
comme s'est illustré avec son plan de
sauvegarde du fret et qu'elle cherchera
sa future privatisation
les agents ne cesseront de faire grève
cela s'explique notamment par le fait
que la sncf se trouve enfermé dans une
logique concurrentielle qui la pousse à
augmenter sa rentabilité économique au
détriment d'autres considérations
nous ne pouvons également passer sous
silence le fait que depuis sept ans ce
sont 21 1500 emplois qui ont été
supprimés à la sncf voilà une cause non
seulement qui pourrait expliquer la
conflictuelle it et au sein
d'entreprises mais également expliqué le
défaut de continuité du service public
si les moyens ne sont pas suffisants
pour le garantir
à ce titre comment ne pas voir
qu'aujourd'hui de simples aléas
météorologiques
comme on le voit en ce moment sont
capables de remettre en cause
l'organisation du service public de
transport n'est ce pas le signe que ce
flot fonctionnement à flux tendu et
facteur de grandes perturbations pour
les usagers
cela me permet d'aborder la seule
question qui fait sens pour mon groupe
celle de la continuité du service public
des transports au quotidien et là il
faut bien avouer que celle ci est mise à
mal
cela a été déjà dit par les orateurs
précédents non par les grèves répétées
mais bien le sous-investissement
chronique dont fait l'objet ce secteur
d'activité les entreprises de
libéralisation venait sous les
injonctions de bruxelles
ainsi selon le rapport du député mariton
le nombre de jours de grève par agent
était de 0 18 en 2008 par conséquent
faire des grèves
l'unique mal dont souffre aujourd'hui le
service public en termes de continuité
est une contre vérité
je rappelle que les grèves ne sont
représentatifs que de 3 % de l'ensemble
des incidents qui perturbe les
transports
en réalité le problème du service public
des transports réside essentiellement
sur la tension extrême des réseaux qui
pâtissent de l'insuffisance des
investissements depuis les années 70 la
diminution continue des crédits
tecteo transport ne peut conduire qu'à
une rupture de la continuité du service
public
les conflits sont également nourries par
la dégradation des conditions sociales
sur les coups de boutoir de la
déréglementation du secteur
la précarité de l'emploi se développe
dans les transports avec une aggravation
des temps partiel les salariés sont non
fondées et exiger une autre politique
des transports avec les associations
d'usagers
nous continuons d'affirmer la nécessité
d'un plan marshall des transports qui
doit être initiée par l'état et les
collectivités
à ce titre je souhaite souligner que les
financements des collectivités notamment
celles des régions vont être fortement
impacté par la réforme des collectivités
et la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle
à ce titre nous souhaitons que l'état
s'engage dans un effort financier sans
précédent notamment par le biais d'une
reprise de la dette de rff
nous regrettons que dans les sommes
affectées au grand emprunt aucune ne
corresponde à ce défi majeur est que les
déclarations d'intention lors du
grenelle de l'environnement ne soit pas
eu le suivi suivi des investissements
correspondants les sénateurs communistes
républicains citoyens se place pour leur
part résolument du côté de la défense du
service public de la qualité de la
sécurité des prestations fournies pour
les usagers cette volonté est
indissociable des conditions de travail
des personnels du respect des droits
collectifs et de droits syndicaux et de
la négociation dans les entreprises pour
cette raison nous sommes opposés à toute
atteinte au droit de grève droit
indispensable et utile pour chaque
citoyen salariés je vous remercie je
m'excuse le 7 minutes remercie chaque
collègue la parole et à monsieur michel
teston s'il vous plaît
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre cheikh chers collègues lors de
la campagne présidentielle nicolas
sarkozy avait annoncé son intention
d'instaurer un service minimum dans les
transports je le cite je garantirai
trois heures de transport en commun pour
aller au travail et trois heures pour en
revenir
il est inacceptable que les français
soient pris en otage par les grèves
fin de citation peu de temps après son
élection à la présidence de la
république de manière quelque peu
démagogique
suivant la logique des effets d'annoncé
ou des lois déclarative il a fait
déposer le 7 juillet 2007 un projet de
loi qui a été examiné en session
extraordinaire par le sénat est adoptée
par le parlement
selon la procédure d'urgence ce texte
qui est en retrait par rapport aux
engagements du candidat sarkozy comprend
trois principaux volets le premier volet
prévoit que les entreprises de transport
les organisations syndicales de salariés
négocié avant le 1er janvier 2008 un
accord concernant l'organisation
obligatoire d'une négociation avant le
dépôt de tout préavis de grève des
négociations peuvent être en parallèle
menée au niveau de la branche
professionnelle
le deuxième volet vise à permettre la
mise en oeuvre d'un service garanti en
cas de grève ou de perturbations
prévisibles
ce service minimum est définie par les
autorités organisatrices de transport en
fonction des spécificités locales pardon
deux mesures principales sont mises en
place l'obligation pour les salariés de
déclarer 48 heures avant le début d'une
grève s'ils ont l'intention d'y
participer et la possibilité après huit
jours de grève d'organiser à
l'initiative de l'employeur ou d'une
organisation syndicale
un vote indicatif à bulletin secret sur
sa poursuite un amendement adopté par le
sénat
prévoit qu'un médiateur pourra
intervenir dès le début de la grève le
troisième volet fait obligation à
l'entreprise de transport d'informer
préalablement les usagers en cas de
grève ou de perturbations prévisibles
celle ci peut être tenue de rembourser
en tout ou partie les usagers en cas de
non mise en oeuvre d'un plan de
transport adapté le texte réaffirme
enfin que les jours de grève ne peuvent
donner lieu à paiement
ce texte a suscité à juste titre de
fortes réactions de la part des
organisations syndicales de salariés
elle considère en effet que l'objectif
du gouvernement n'est pas d'améliorer le
dialogue social mais de restreindre le
droit de grève
lors des débats si les intervenants de
notre groupe ont approuvé l'idée de
prévenir plus efficacement la survenance
de conflits sociaux par l'instauration
d'un dispositif de négociation
collective obligatoire
ils ont par contre formulé de nombreuses
et vives critiques sur pratiquement
toutes les autres dispositions qu'il
contient ainsi nous avons souligné que
le texte n'évoque pas les questions de
la dégradation du service public des
transports et du vieillissement du
réseau ainsi que les multiples incidents
notamment des dégradations volontaires à
l'origine de nombreuses perturbations
nous avons aussi relevé que ce texte
ignore les grèves dites émotionnel
déclenchée dans l'instant à la suite
d'agressions d'agents il nous est apparu
aussi clairement que ce texte fait peser
sur les élus à savoir les autorités
organisatrices de transport des
responsabilités qui ne sont pas les
leurs il est pourtant évident que ce ne
sont pas les autorités organisatrices de
transport mais des entreprises de
transport qui sont responsables ils of
social avec leurs salariés
plus généralement nous avons dénoncé une
loi d'affichage reprenant ainsi
l'expression de digne maso professeur de
droit à assas nous avons aussi formulé
trois autres critiques majeures à
l'égard de ce texte
première critique alors que la majorité
nationale avait déjà fait voter la loi
du 4 mai 2004 relative à la formation
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
au dialogue social et celle du 31
janvier 2007 de modernisation du
dialogue social
il lui a semblé nécessaire de proposer
un troisième texte
faut-il en tirer la conclusion que les
dispositifs précédents ne s'était pas
révélée à la hauteur des enjeux
en tout cas c'est ce que nous avons dit
en juillet 2007
deuxième grande critique ce texte réduit
la portée du droit de grève et le débat
sur l'amélioration du dialogue social
est en trompe l'oeil peut-on parler
d'amélioration du dialogue social avec
la mise en place de sanctions
disciplinaires à l'encontre des salariés
grévistes
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas par exemple
respecter l'obligation de déclaration
préalable sur leur intention de faire
grève
troisième critique il est faux
d'affirmer que cette loi permet
d'assurer un service minimum effectif
tout au plus un gîte il d'un service
restreint et surtout d'un service
hypothétique
en effet si tous les salariés sont en
grève il est bien évident que le service
ne sera pas assuré je rappelle que 80 %
environ des agents sont nécessaires pour
assurer un service normal aux heures de
pointe en particulier dans les grandes
agglomérations
alors qu'aux yeux cette analyse du
projet de loi
le groupe socialiste c'est en juillet
2007 prononcée contre son adoption
depuis lors que s'est il passé si le
conseil constitutionnel a validé la loi
le bureau international du travail la
décla déclaré non conforme à la
convention numéro 87 de l'oit et sur la
liberté syndicale la protection du droit
syndical
en effet selon le bit et je le cite la
fixation d'un service minimum négocié
devrait être limitée aux opérations
strictement nécessaires pour que la
satisfaction des besoins de base de la
population ou des exigences minimales du
service soit assurée
car elle limite l'un des moyens de
pression essentiels dont disposent les
travailleurs pour défendre leurs
intérêts économiques et sociaux
fin de citation en outre face à une loi
30 à relativiser le droit de grève les
salariés ont développé on le comprend de
nouvelles formes d'action qui en contre
car les effets l'article 10 de la loi
dispose que je cite la rémunération des
salariés participant à la grève y
compris les avantages directs et
indirects est réduite au prorata de la
durée non travaillées à l'exclusion des
suppléments pour charge de famille
fin de citation cette rédaction ouvre
une brèche dans laquelle s'est engouffré
le syndicat sud en janvier 2009 lors des
grèves à la gare saint lazare à paris et
à nice les salariés sont déclarés
grévistes pendant 59 minutes par jour ce
qui leur permet de limiter leurs pertes
de salaire tout en apportant une
certaine désorganisation au trafic
de même les cheminots ont pu largement
utilisé et là aussi on les comprend le
droit de retrait à la suite d'agressions
de collègues ce qui a provoqué notamment
la fermeture complète de la gare saint
lazare le 12 janvier 2009
bloquant quatre cent mille voyageurs
quant à l'obligation faite aux salariés
d'annoncer 48 heures à l'avancé son
intention de faire grève
sous peine de sanctions disciplinaires
elle a pour conséquence d'inciter tous
salariés déclarés grévistes préalable
même si cette déclaration n'est pas
suivi d'effet aussi un trafic peut être
annoncé comme très perturbé et se
réveiller par la suite moins de coucher
avec comme conséquence une information
erronée donné à l'usagé à d'autres
effets négatifs de la loi a été constaté
les entreprises de transport ne peuvent
être contraintes par l'autorité
organisatrice de transport de rembourser
des titres de transport si elles ont mis
en place un plan de transport qui a
fonctionné et ce même si les usagers ont
subi une gêne considérable
ainsi la ratp a refusé de procéder à des
remboursements
après la grève du rer a
fin 2009 début 2010 dans ce contexte
quelle évaluation pour nous faire de ce
service 10 minimum deux ans après son
entrée en vigueur
globalement si les demandes de
concertation obligatoire ont bien été
effectués il n'en reste pas moins que le
nombre de conflits a augmenté récemment
libération faisait état du fait qu'en
les préavis ont été davantage suivis par
des conflits qu en 2007 le dispositif a
en outre largement montré ses limites
dans le cadre de grèves massives
enfin il a été contrecarrée par de
nouvelles modalités d'actions mises en
place par les salariés grèves de 59
minutes usage plus systématiques du
droit de retrait
grèves tournantes le 4 mars 2009 nos
collègues députés jacques kossowski et
maxime bono ont déposé un rapport
concernant l'application de la loi de
2006 estime que globalement ce texte est
correctement appliquée il rappelle
également qu'il n'a pas créé de réelle
service minimum celui ci nécessitant la
mise en place de réquisition de
personnels dès lors je me tourner vers
ma collègue madame trop cachia avec
l'organisation de ce débat
l'objectif du conte fumée pays du sénat
n'est-il pas de préparer en réalité le
terrain au vote d'une nouvelle loi
visant à restreindre encore le droit de
grève des salariés des entreprises de
transport et cher veut pour preuve le
dépôt en février 2009 de la proposition
de loi du député ciotti et de plusieurs
de ses collègues ump
cette proposition a pour but de mettre
en place un pouvoir de réquisition
dévolu aux préfets de contraindre les
autorités organisatrices de transport à
mettre en place des listes d'agents
volontaires pour suppléer leurs
collègues en cas de grève spontané alors
qu'eric ciotti et ses collègues pensent
que la loi de 2007 est insuffisante
le rapport kossowski mme ono s'oppose à
l'idée de légiférer
dans l'urgence et hachée pour trois
raisons principales première raison le
texte de 2007 dette en vigueur que
depuis deux ans il faut lui laisser sur
les auteurs du rapport ne les cite le
terme de vivre et d'être socialement
bien acceptée fin de citation deuxième
raison la grève n'est pas loin s'en faut
la cause principale des perturbations du
trafic
concernant la ratp par exemple le
président de l'entreprise rappelle que
les causes de perturbations sont dans
l'ordre les suicides et tentatives de
suicide
les utilisations abusives du signal
d'alarmé par les usagers les malaises
d'usagé les colis suspect les problèmes
d'infrastructures les défaillances
matérielles et enfin les causes sociales
troisième raison enfin légiférer dans
l'urgence en pensant que énième texte va
empêcher les conflits
c'est oublier que le problème de fond
est celui du dialogue social
c'est un problème qui doit être traitée
en priorité au final le texte nous et
michettes est loin d'avoir eu les effets
promis par le gouvernement le directeur
du transport public à la sncf a évoqué
je le cite l'apparition d'une nouvelle
forme de confidentialité peu pénalisante
pour les grévistes et très
déstabilisante pour l'entreprise
fin de citation en d'autres termes
monsieur le ministre
madame cette loi censée renforcer le
dialogue social et la continuité dans
les services publics a produit l'effet
contraire à savoir
l'exacerbation de la confiture alité
pour autant ce concert doit en aucun cas
justifier une nouvelle réduction du
droit de grève attentant gravement cette
liberté fondamentale
à cet égard la ppl ciotti que j'ai déjà
cité nous paraît attentatoire au droit
de grève est donc contraire au principe
constitutionnel
le constat de l'inefficacité de la loi
ne doit nullement conduire avant dans le
dispositif encore plus contraignants
notre groupe y est opposé au nom du
groupe socialiste je tiens à rappeler ce
qui a déjà été dit mais il est bon de le
rappeler une nouvelle fois
que la majorité des désagréments
nombreux et fréquents chimie par les
usagers des transports n'ont pas pour
origine les mouvements sociaux mais sur
la conséquence du sous investissement
dans l'entretien des réseaux et des
matériels générateur de retard et de pas
la question de fond est donc beaucoup
plus celle des moyens dégagés par l'état
et les entreprises pour faire
fonctionner dans de bonnes conditions
les transports publics terrestres de
voyageurs enfin tout doit être fait pour
renforcer le dialogue social
cette orientation était d'ailleurs
préconisée par le rapport mandelkern en
2004 partant de l'hypothèse qu'il n'est
pas possible en l'état de mettre en
place un service minimum continue en
conclusion notre position reste la même
qu'en 2007
il convient de renforcer le dialogue
social et non d'attiser les conflits
comme l'a fait la loi de 2007 au même si
schalke legs la parole et à madame anne
marie escoffier
monsieur président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues la question orale
dont nous débattons ce soir intervient
fort opportunément au lendemain de la
fin d'une longue grève sur la ligne a du
rer
une grève qui pendant deux semaines à
forte fortement nui aux usagers
parisiens ainsi qu'à de nombreux
habitants de l'ouest et de l'est de la
capitale à sa caisse à cette occasion
s'est posé à nouveau la question du
service minimum le droit de grève dans
les transports publics qui longtemps a
constitué un fonds de propositions des
lois déposé depuis 2002 sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui le débat porte sur les
conditions de mise en oeuvre et les
conséquences de la loi du 21 août 2007
relative au dialogue social et à la
continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres réguliers de
voyageurs
loin de moi de méconnaître le principe
même d'un service minimum est de le
critiquer il existe dans d'autres
secteurs l'hôpital la télévision et il
ne serait pas question de le remettre en
cause
de la même façon et ça a été dit par
notre collègue en europe la moitié des
états constituants l'union ont mis en
place une hésitation à peu près
comparable selon naturellement la nature
de leurs droits et de leur
réglementation
dès lors il n'était pas absurde
d'envisager qu'un service assuré aux
heures de pointe pu non seulement
respecter strictement le droit de grève
mais encore permettre aux usagers de se
rendre sur leur lieu de travail
garantissant ainsi deux pôles
imprescriptible des principes
constitutionnels de la république droit
de grève est libre circulation des
personnes
quelle évaluation peut-on faire
maintenant de ce dispositif je voudrais
relever sur le dernier cas concrets de
la grève du rer
de fait particulier d'abord s'agissant
de l'efficacité du service minimum sur
certaines lignes
les voyageurs n'ont bénéficié que d'un
train sur cinq ou sur six au lieu de 1
train sur 3 comme initialement prévu
en outre les horaires de fonctionnement
de ce service minimum ont été peu
compatible avec une activité
professionnelle habituel trois heures
tôt le matin soit mais fin de service le
soir à 19h30 à 1h qui est loin de
correspondre à la fin du service de
nombreux salariés
il s'en est suivi un recours accru à la
voiture au métro créant par là même
embouteillages et bousculades et parfois
mauvaise humeur
s'agissant en second lieu des
conséquences financières
ce mouvement de grève pour les voyageurs
ceux d'entre eux qui ont acquis un
coupon hebdomadaire assez onéreux et je
pense en particulier aux usagers
habitant le plus loin de paris et aux
revenus modestes
ces usagers se sont interrogés sur les
conditions de remboursement du des
coupons ce à quoi il leur a été répondu
au guichet de la ligne à que puisqu'il y
a eu ses rvices minimum il n'y a pas de
remboursement j'aimerais monsieur mini
faut savoir si cette réponse sera
confirmée par votre administration alors
que vous n'ignorez pas que la qualité de
ce service n'a pas été à la hauteur de
ce que les voyageurs sont en droit
d'attendre
je voudrais maintenant de façon plus
générale vous faire part de mes
observations sur ce dispositif
le bilan d'application de la loi sur le
service minimum est aux dires mêmes de
la sncf et de la ratp mitigé parce que
variable selon les territoires
si globalement les départements ayant en
charge par exemple les transports
interurbains et scolaires rencontre peu
de difficultés en matière de continuité
de service public
il en va tout autrement dans certaines
régions ou dans certaines entreprises de
transport urbain les difficultés
inhérentes à la mise en place d'un
service minimum à l'image de celle que
je viens d'évoquer se trouve encore
amplifiée lors de ces grèves spontanées
dit grève émotionnelle comme celle
récemment déclenché à
antoine azar à la suite de l'agression
d'un conducteur
là se trouve une des failles de la loi
du 21 août 2007 qui ne répond pas à la
problématique des grèves imprévus ou de
ces grèves de courte durée dit de 59
minutes ou de ces mouvements de
personnel qui inopinément décide de
faire grève ou tout aussi inopinément de
renoncer à la même rêve je mesure bien
sûr pour l'opérateur la difficulté à
prévoir l'imprévisible et à ajuster le
trafic en temps réel ou presque aux
besoins des usagers face à des
situations de cette nature qui posent au
demeurant la question du dépôt de
préavis successifs la commission des
affaires économiques de l'assemblée
nationale a souhaité la création d'un
observatoire des relations sociales dans
les transports terrestres
doté de tous les pouvoirs
d'investigation nécessaire est appelé à
faire un bilan de l'état du dialogue
social en france un tel observatoire
serait de nature à permettre un examen
impartial de la situation des
entreprises de transport et son
positionnement indépendant le garantir
et de toute instrumentalisation dans un
conflit je voudrais en effet souligné
que le plus grand nombre du mouvement de
grève se veut le révélateur d'un malaise
est liée le plus souvent à la qualité du
transport attendu tant des voyageurs
eux-mêmes que des salariés
l'augmentation exponentielle du nombre
de voyageurs le vieillissement et la
dégradation des équipements le besoin de
formation des conducteurs l'insécurité
sont autant de freins à la bonne marche
des trains bien plus que les conflits
sociaux
il provoque la majorité de retards ou
des perturbations de trafic
le président de la république a
opportunément parlé de la nécessité
d'arrêter un plan d'amélioration de la
ligne e à monsieur le ministre pouvait
vous sur ce plan particulier nous dire
les objectifs les modalités de
financement son calendrier de mise en
oeuvre vos réponses viendront apporter
quelques apaisement dans un contexte
social tendu
qui mériterait assurément que soit
instauré un nouveau dialogue social plus
serein que celui vécu ces dernières
semaines je veux être persuadé monsieur
le ministre que votre objectif est bien
avant tout de garantir un service public
de transport de qualité dont
bénéficieront aussi bien les voyageurs
écouté et entendu dans leurs attentes
légitimes que les salariés de ces
services publics respectés pour leur
engagement au quotidien au service du
public
je remercie chers collègues la parole et
à monsieur louis
s'il vous plaît
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues à
l'initiative du sénat et en particulier
de notre éminent collègue madame
catherine provocation vient en débat
l'évaluation de la loi sur la continuité
des services publics de transport ceci
montre tout à la fois la réactivité de
notre assemblée l'attention que les
sénateurs portent au quotidien de nos
concitoyens
de même que la sa sensibilité à la
maintenance de services publics de
grande qualité
je rappelle que ces derniers sont un des
éléments majeurs monsieur le ministre
aux yeux des investisseurs étrangers de
l'attractivité de la france et donc de
son développement économique qui nous
concerne tous directement la loi du 21
août 2007 n'impose pas contrairement à
ce que l'on croit trop souvent un niveau
de service minimale mais portent plus
simplement sur le dialogue social et la
continuité du service public dans les
transports terrestres réguliers de
voyageurs
cette loi voulue par le président de la
république suite aux profonds
dysfonctionnements constatés dans le
secteur des transports était
incontestablement nécessaire
elle a eu un impact positif sur le
dialogue social en organisant de manière
précise ces modalités
le dispositif de prévention des conflits
a globalement bien fonctionné et
l'impact sur la conflictuelle it et
s'est avéré positif
parallèlement le constat des
professionnels au plan national et qu'en
cas de grève l'application de la loi
s'est traduite souvent par un service
supérieur à la prévision
enfin les plans que ce soit les plans de
transport adapté et les plans de
l'information des usagers ont été pour
leur grande majorité respecter cette loi
qui était nécessaire je le répète a eu
comme nous venons de le constater un
résultat positif tant au niveau du
dialogue social que pour l'information
des usagers pour autant
pour autant peut-on en déduire que tout
est pour le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes
malheureusement la réponse à cette
question est incontestablement non la
très graves perturbations qu'a connu
pendant deux mois la région paca l'année
dernière le mouvement actuel qui
perturbent une unité de production de
marseille blancarde et les récents
événements en ile-de-france notamment la
grève sur la ligne du rer a ont montré
que malgré une certaine pertinence de la
loi de 2007
cette dernière était bien nécessaire
mais insuffisante pour assurer à nos
concitoyens les droits constitutionnels
de liberté de circulation et de liberté
d'accès aux services publics
le problème qui se pose à nous chers
collègues et celui du respect minimal
que l'on doit aux usagers
constitutionnellement lui aussi reconnu
à travers la continuité du service
public et de l'importance que la nation
veut bien accorder au secteur des
transports la constitution de son côté
précise que le droit de grève s'exerce
dans le cadre de la loi article 7
cette précision juridique vise confirmer
qu'il n'y a pas un droit de grève dans
l'absolu mais un droit de grève relatif
en fonction du domaine où il s'exerce
c'est d'ailleurs si vrai qu'il existe un
service minimum dans les secteurs aussi
sensibles que le nucléaire l'audiovisuel
la santé le contrôle aérien ce dernier
nos domaines nous amène à nous
interroger et ailleurs sur la
distinction actuel qui privilégie donc
les français d'en haut
ceux qui prennent l'avion sur les
français d'en bas qui eux sont soumis
aux aléas des transports terrestres la
question résoudre est donc de savoir si
les transports publics terrestres sont
des services essentiels pour le pays et
les français
qui peut nier l'importance de ses
services le rôle majeur dans le bon
fonctionnement de la société
pauvres usagers qui sont les oubliés
permanent boire les otages ces conflits
du travail
dont ils sont les premières et les
principales victimes qui pense à eux
cette question se pose d'autant plus
qu'on l'a dit tout à l'heure en cas de
grève de la totalité du personnel
les usagers ne bénéficient même plus
d'un minimum de services en europe des
pays aussi démocratique au moins aussi
démocratique que la france ont donné une
réponse différente chers collègues à la
nôtre beaucoup plus favorable aux
usagers en allemagne ou en autriche
je rappelle qu'il est interdit
constitutionnellement parlant de faire
grève au salarié statutaires de la
fonction publique c'est excessif compte
tenu de notre culture
très bien alors prenons d'autres pays
européens l'italie l'espagne ou là
encore le droit de la communauté aux
prestations vital tant les transports
est prioritaire sur le droit de grève
par ailleurs peut-on par ad'ailleurs
foot ni raisonnablement que les intérêts
particuliers de quelques centaines
d'employés s'impose à un million de
voyageurs dans la dignité le droit au
travail sont à mes yeux au moins aussi
important le droit des usagers d'aller
devenir ne peut être pris en otage par
une infime minorité de travailleurs qui
a je le rappel des droits mais aussi des
devoirs
ce conflit catégorie elle a produit une
grève qui a très durement pénalisé des
centaines de milliers de français
est ce normal non est ce légitime non
dans le cadre de l'évaluation de la loi
de 2007
ce dysfonctionnement majeur confirme que
cette dernière loi ne sanctionne pas le
déséquilibre manifestement excessifs
entre les deux principes
constitutionnels de même niveau et un
tout aussi grave déséquilibre entre une
infime minorité qui fait peser une
contrainte excessive sur une énorme
majorité de nos concitoyens usagers
cette situation est donc pas trop
déséquilibrée et ce au détriment des
sans grades du vulgum pecus qui ne
méritent pas cependant
une telle indifférence chaque collègue
il appartient au législatif de faire
évoluer cette loi dans un sens plus
équitable monsieur ministre s'en aller a
contesté le droit de grève comme en
autriche en allemagne sens aller jusqu à
réquisitionner plus facilement par les
préfets les salariés du secteur
mais pour tenir compte de l'état de
souffrance d'abandon des principaux
intéressés
je devrais plutôt dire des naufragés les
transports publics
je propose à ce jour et sous réserve
d'une évaluation annuelle six mesures
pour tenir compte des abus 1
on renforce la loyauté entre partenaires
du dialogue social et en conséquence on
prévoit désormais pour une grève de
moins d'une heure une retenue financière
égale du montant du salaire du pour la
durée totale du service 2 de confirmer
par la loi la jurisprudence qui jugent
illicites les grèves tournantes 3 de
fixer la déclaration des grévistes 48
heures avant le début théorique de la
grève et non pas 48 heures avant le
moment de la participation personnelle
du salarié se termine dans les cas 4 des
mouvements de grève nationaux de
supprimer la larme sociale et de
conserver uniquement le prix à vis de
cinq jours ainsi que la procédure de
déclaration des grévistes de fixer plus
précisément les limites des grèves
promotionnelle eu des grèves émotionnel
ce président pour éviter les abus de
droit de retrait et en faire monsieur le
président l'internaute de supprimer
l'alternance répété à l'intérieur d'une
période couverte par un préavis d'arrêt
de travail de reprise d'activité par un
même salarié alors tout à l'heure
monsieur le président chers collègues
notre collègue monsieur testant michel
teston nous demander quel était
l'objectif de l'ump
eh bien c'était de défendre le peuple
merci jacques allet n'a pas en l'état
monsieur jacques gauthier
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai un peu
l'impression depuis le début de la
soirée que certains refont le débat de
2730 leurs interventions sur le
vieillissement des matériels roulants le
manque de confort et des régularités je
tiens à dire chemise que c'est un point
que je partage totalement
nous devons faire des efforts dans ce
domaine
mais ce n'est pas le sujet de ce soir
notre débat concerne une évaluation et
peut-être on viens de l'entendre un
renforcement de la loi de 2007 sur le
dialogue social et la continuité du
service public des transports
alors cette loi on l'a répété s'applique
maintenant depuis deux ans et je me
félicite que ma collègue catherine
procaccia et souhaité que nous dressions
ensemble cette évaluation qui a aussi
pour objet rappelons le en cas de
conflit social de permettre aux usagers
de se déplacer d'aller travailler ou de
rentrer chez eux aux airs de pointe
tout cela en respectant la liberté
fondamentale du droit de grève
si le bilan de ce dispositif semble
globalement positif et la grève du 29
janvier 2009
anne est un exemple 35% de grévistes
mais la sncf avait réussi à maintenir
près de 50% des trains sans parler des
grèves qui n'ont pas eu lieu grâce au
dialogue social renforcé mais on se rend
compte aussi qu'au travers des
opérations d'arrêt de travail limitée à
59 minutes et répétitive on l'a évoqué
ou pendant des événements récents sur la
ligne a du rer
le service garanti a été insuffisant en
effet et beaucoup l'ont évoquée pendant
17 jours du 10 au 27 décembre dernier un
million de franciliens qui empruntent
chaque jour la ligne à la plus
fréquentée d'europe
a subi la plus longue grève depuis 1995
dans ce cas le service garanti dans les
transports n'a pas apporté de réponse
satisfaisante
les usagers se sont entassés dans les
gares dans le froid et les trains qui
circulent est obligé de partir très tôt
le matin et souvent de rentrée très tard
le soir quand ils n'étaient pas forcés
de ne pas aller travailler
faute d'un service acceptable si la
paralysie a été vite et c'est peut-être
grâce à la loi mais je rappelle que
c'est souvent les plus modestes qui ont
été pris en otage et le surveille ce
public que beaucoup revendique ce soir
n'a pas été à la hauteur de ce que nous
sommes en droit d'attendre et d'offrir à
nos concitoyens
j'ajoute que dans un contexte économique
difficile
et juste avant la fin de l'année au
moment des fêtes
ce conflit a eu des répercussions
économiques lourdes pour les entreprises
les commerces les petits commerçants et
les entreprises de commerce et les
usagers la ratp l'a estimé à sanyo
d'euros ce qui la concerne et les
commerçants et entreprises de commerce
aurait perdu plus de 50 millions d'euros
d'après le medef ile de france
cela n'est pas acceptable il est donc
nécessaire de chez les ministres d'aller
plus loin pour assurer un véritable
service des transports publics
de plus je voudrais signaler cannes
ile-de-france le partage des transports
entre ratp et sncf ne fait qu'aggraver
dans certains cas la pénalisation des
usagers il est donc nécessaire que nous
intégrions cette dimension dans notre
réflexion cela même au moment où la
commission spéciale sur le grand paris
vient de se mettre en place ce grand
paris dont le projet phare s'articule
sur une double boucle de transport en
commun
certes automatique et dont on voit bien
que quelques techniciens pourrait
maintenant le rendre inutilisable
perturber son fonctionnement pour
terminer mon intervention je voudrais
revenir sur le titre de 2007 dans le cas
le gouvernement catherine procaccia
l'adie n'avait pas souhaité prendre en
compte le volet de transport aérien et
les liaisons maritimes entre la france
et les hits de sa façade maritime
nous sommes en train de vivre